hmm
you clicked the video not just any video
my video with all these videos on
youtube you clicked mine but why did you
click mine what are you telling me i
need you to watch this video and i need
to find you because you
are my you
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host joe aka the guy who always
gets out of a relationship in the nick
of time and this video we're going to be
talking about you season four apologies
for the creepy intro but i just thought
i'd have some fun and yes you definitely
want to reply to me when i dm you 500
times now even before season 3 released
it was announced by netflix on the 13th
of october that the series was going to
be heading into its fourth season with
that ending it's clear that they're
taking the show in a different direction
and we're sort of back to square one
with joe shedding all of his
responsibilities all of the seasons
preceding it ended with joe seeing
someone new and then getting swept up in
them or as the latest sentry had him
still fixated on marianne it must be
love love love oh wait love is dead and
instead we ended with the idea that he
would spend his time in paris trying to
search for her now he'd not only killed
his wife but he'd also left his son
henry behind and it was very much a
fresh start for joe who is now going
under the name nick now we will be
getting into our theories for season 4
in just a bit but in the meantime i want
to talk about what we know first netflix
have clearly been working on the overall
arc of the show for a long time and the
second season ended up getting 457
million viewers in its first 28 days so
it's clear that the series has a big
following penn batchly has of course
been confirmed as returning and when
discussing the upcoming series sharon
and sarah gamble said that next time
will show an even darker facet of love
i'm not sure how much darker you can get
than paralyzing your wife cutting off
your toe and then burning your house
down but who knows as we're getting into
pretty wild territory now one of the
things i have been wanting to see is the
lore catch up to joe but with him faking
his own death and being in a completely
new country i think that it'll be a long
time before his past comes back to haunt
him he is however clearly on the lookout
for marianne who did say she was going
to paris with her daughter taddy
gabrielle who plays the character
recently talked about this with marie
claire but she said that she couldn't
tell them whether she was gonna be in
the series or not now making it sound
like it was a flat out no however she
did tease that netflix we're keeping
things under wraps so in my personal
opinion she's just been told to keep
shtum and she definitely will be back
now what she was allowed to talk about
was what she thought the character was
up to and she said the following i do
think she's in france i like what she
taught i can't do women's voices i do i
do think she's in france like what she
talks to joe about i feel like she would
either be like an art teacher or a fully
commissioned artist i would just want
her to find the piece she's been seeking
to do art and let her kid have the most
free and lovely life and for them to be
happy now this is sort of teased at in
the final few shots of the season in
which we see joe walking past some
paintings outside of an art shop he's
clearly chosen these types of locations
to be close to on the off chance that
marianne pops up there either looking at
the work or displaying her own i think
this final shot was put in place for a
reason to hint that to us and it'll be
interesting to see if it ties together
teddy gabrielle seems to think so and
those final scenes have a number of
things in them that kind of hint to us
what's going to be happening next and i
would also love to see victoria pedra
return as a sort of ghost much in the
same way that 40 did at one point in
season three now though it wouldn't be a
massive role seeing her back in the
series would be a pretty big cameo and
i'd love to see joe russell with his
inner psyche there's also the flashbacks
in which we see him as a child as well
as his mother the both of which i'm
guessing will be returning interestingly
season 3 teased that he now has a half
brother and i'd love to see this
character pop up as an adult in joe's
life now as for the release date though
things haven't been set in stone yet we
can kind of use the past releases as a
guide to guess when things will be
coming out season 2 was released on the
26th of november 2019 and there was just
over a 13 month gap between that and the
first entry which was released in
november 2018. a lot of people don't
know that this show was originally
released on the lifetime network but
they ended up selling it to netflix who
took things forward with season two the
air gap between entries would have had
the latest release dropping last year
but unfortunately the pandemic got in
the way because of this it did kind of
make things more difficult to estimate
but i would guess that the next season
will probably drop at either the end of
the next year or at the start of 2023
it's a long time away but with his show
being so popular i doubt that netflix
will want to pump the brakes on it now
as for the plot and our theories i think
we can actually look at the book that
the work is based on for some pointers
at where things are going the source
material is actually a fair bit
different to the show and in that joe
gets arrested for his connection to
beck's death whilst he's in jail love
gives birth and on the outside the pair
don't raise their child together love
also isn't a murderer and whereas she's
pretty much michael myers in the tv show
she kills no one in the books her
husband even died during a surfing
accident so it's a pretty big departure
from what we see now in the book
marianne is actually called mary kay and
similar to what we get the pair get to
know each other when working at the
library mary kay is actually married at
the time and her husband dies of a drug
overdose whilst she and joe are having
an affair her husband's brother comes to
live with them but he gets in a lot of
legal trouble and ends up selling the
house in order to pay for lawyers this
leaves mary kay out on her own with
nowhere for her and her daughter to stay
and thus they move in with joe joe ends
up proposing and no i don't think that
the third season will follow this
completely i do think that he will
manufacture a way for them to end up
living together in paris i actually
think that marianne will reject him
though and that she'll find herself in a
very similar situation to how she was
with her ex where he ends up trying to
control her marianne left town without
saying absolutely anything and it's
clear she wanted to get away from things
after learning the truth about joe i
think they could do something really
interesting in the show and potentially
even bring across elements of lockdown
at the end of the season they do pay lip
service to the pandemic and though it
seems to be said after the majority of
lockdowns have happened they could still
bring it in i think it would be a stroke
of genius if marianne and joe ended up
living together and then joe tricked her
into believing that there was a lockdown
so that she had to stay in the house
with him it's a bit far-fetched you know
but yeah that was just something i think
would be pretty wild to see now there's
also ellie from season 2 who did get
name dropped in the third entry we
learned that joe had been sending her
money but if this suddenly stopped it
may make her want to come forward and
expose what she suspected about him in
love learning of his death might make
her be the one he reveals he's the kind
of guy who would fake things and he
could send the lore after joe much like
in the books as i've said i do think
that at some point his past needs to
catch up with him as he can't really
keep just doing this forever and there
does need to be some comeuppance
marianne also now knows what's going on
but unlike love she doesn't really seem
to have a darker side to her she will
not cover for murders like love did i
think if anyone tells the authorities
about him that it should be her either
way there's a lot to talk about and if
you enjoyed this video we'd massively
appreciate the thumbs up and also
subscribe now as a thank you for doing
that you'll be entered into a
competition on the 30th of october in
which we're giving away three copies of
the mcu phase three box set all you have
to do to begin with a chance of winning
is like the video make sure that you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the video we pick the comments at random
at the end of the month and the winners
of the last one are on screen right now
so that's you then message me on twitter
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of season 3 which will be
linked on screen right now we talk about
the themes in it the plot and also give
our thoughts on the ending so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
love the season as much as we did
without the way thank you for singing
through the video i've been paul and
i'll see you on the next one take care
peace